Assassin's Creed rogue is painfully lazy
in places it's missions are darlin there
aren't enough of them its lead character
is a walking antihero cliche well you
know trouble just follows me around and
it's basically a glorified Black Flag
DLC pack but let's start with the story
the hero will antihero in this case is
Shay Patrick Cormac a gruff moody
assassin out for a revenge after
becoming disillusioned with the
Brotherhood yes the Assassin's Creed
series still hasn't discovered that
there are character motivations outside
of surly angry dude which Shay's
spending most of his time shouting out
and killing other surly angry dudes
before going off on his own to stare off
into space and contemplate why everyone
is just so gosh darn mean to him your
simpleton your rat brain cabbage farmer
so know the core character's story isn't
going to keep you glued to this screen
particularly as the voice acting and
it's less than convincing Irish accents
have a distinct B feel team to them I
got no Gryba my boss sent me over huh
and where is he set up but while I've
never cared for it much myself the
surrounding law is going to be of huge
interest to series fans rogue fills in
many of the gaps between a c3 and Black
Flag by diving into the Abstergo and
Templar conspiracies as well as
reintroducing some key historical
characters a lot of this is accomplished
during the historical missions but
there's also a return to the often
derided modern-day first-person sections
of Black Flag thankfully these sections
are much shorter this time around and
say for a painfully parkie Abstergo
employee rather Pleasant there's a lot
of information to uncover from data pans
with tongue-in-cheek references to other
Assassin's Creed games to computers with
assassins profiles that are unlocked via
a nifty puzzle game as for the
historical missions well a cliche it may
be but given that Rogue is mechanically
identical to Black Flag if you weren't
into the boats and battles on the high
seas rogue certainly isn't going to
change your mind on the matter it
doesn't help that there's a lack of
interesting missions while story-driven
side quests are few and far between
there are gang bases to liberate though
and these provide some of the most tense
and
facing moments in the game for a game
with assassin in the title there aren't
actually a whole lot of assassinations
to play through and those that are there
tend to involve your target running off
and you chasing them the slow methodical
and far more interesting assassinations
that you'd hope for are few and far
between and so it falls to the seafaring
missions to pick up the slack and while
the thrill of sailing on the open sea
hasn't lost any of his charm you can't
help but feel that with the slim amount
of missions on offer both out at sea and
on dry land that you're getting a raw
deal
there's not even any multiplayer to
round things out outside of a few new
additions like an air rifle and a
grenade launcher there's next to nothing
in robe that moves the franchise's
forward and even if you simply wanted
more black flag that the missions are so
sparse basically difficult to want to
drag yourself across the vast expanse of
rose oceans instead of a rich fleshed
out game rogue is a short Marlee
entertaining adventure that's thin on
core content but thick with information
that's enough give back to my
description I'm sure killing I cannot I
will not let this happen again how those
souls lost one more hardly matters
Shay